the lovely ladies of the view are at it
again the female powered show wasting no
time in attacking Republican women
Whoopi Goldberg completely losing it
over Nikki Haley's presidential campaign
announcement
Nikki
you know since you have been asleep all
this time and you just woke up
you're just finding out that there are
things about our country that are not
perfect
and for us to pretend that it is and
that nothing happened is ridiculous so
you're not saying anything new but the
idiocy doesn't end there Wolfie can't
tell the difference between these two
Republican Senators who have the same
last name
we do deserve to have two strong parties
so you know Tim Scott black Tim Scott
right because there are two Scots and I
I don't know how to differentiate them
without a picture so
Rick Scott and Tim Scott right Tim Scott
is black right okay
you know what's amazing about all of
them is they they play the the the race
card all the time but then when you have
a conservative who's a woman and is a
considers herself and is a woman of
color oh they want to trash her
immediately so Sunny haasan previously
trashed Nikki Haley when she said she
was a chameleon for using the name Nikki
when Sunny uses the name Sunny instead
of Asuncion because we can't pronounce
it remember that Jesse Yeah Sunny will
be Joy all of them are ridiculous I
don't know it's it's a Dodge because we
want to talk about policy but Democrats
never want to talk about policy they
just want to talk about identity and
it's such a cop-out and the Republican
party is dying to talk about policy the
Border transgender bathroom policy
inflation whatever it is but you can't
have a conversation if every time you
say something they say you're a bigot or
they talk about the color of your skin
it's just so annoying with these people
and they think they have the moral High
Ground when they play the race card but
they actually don't and you're listening
to a woman of color who's a millionaire
who changed her name to sound Jewish and
dates white guys talk about how racist
America is how is that even is it racist
or if it is racist would be give us some
advice on how to become a millionaire
celebrity uh as a woman of color that
would be helpful you know uh Geraldo
Nikki Haley mentioned Joe Biden several
times but her her true opponent is
really Donald Trump right now oh yeah
sure but can I say one thing about the
view just if I may uh the secret I think
to unlocking the view is it's even
though they speak about race it's not
about race even though they speak about
gender it's not about gender it's about
ideology it's a very ideologically
driven show they they believe their
philosophy is very Progressive they
believe it and everything else is is a
device to accomplish that goal now in
terms of Nikki Haley
I I say right on girlfriend go for it
it's uh you know she's taking on the the
big lion in the cave I I'm filled with
admiration I've I've met her a couple of
times I think she's very very uh sounds
very confident she was a good Ambassador
she's a great Governor uh she was
governor during that awful uh uh
Massacre down there she uh I I think
she'll be a formidable candidate I don't
know where she's going to get the money
I don't know where any of them are going
to get the tens of millions they'll need
one of the things uh Dana that she says
is that the Republicans have lost a
popular vote in seven of the last eight
presidential elections and failing to
win the confidence of the majority of
Americans Nikki Haley feels that she is
part of the new generation that can
accomplish that so so we'll see how that
goes right so I thought she looked
pretty confident today and she was
cheerful and joyful out there
um the thing about this one is that I
just I just love it when you see women
supporting other women it's really
really warms the heart and you just have
to admire where how the view really
supports women it's very admirable and
we thank you for all of that support
they think that you're only a real
minority if you have a Democrat next to
your name and I think that what they
don't realize is that that actually
helps Nikki Haley they wanted to hurt
Nikki Haley comments like that about the
view help Nikki Haley because then or
we're talking about it here and she can
figure out a way to say oh look now they
want to go after me just like they want
to go after every other Republican she's
not trying to win the vote of Whoopi
Goldberg she's trying to figure out a
way to see if she could possibly get
enough votes to win a Republican primary
the last thing I would say is Sonny said
that she was a political grifter which I
don't even know I don't think she knows
what that means because that would mean
that you're not there to make money for
it there's actually
Nikki Haley was one of the ones she
would travel anywhere she would campaign
for anybody if you called and asked her
and she was a really good campaigner and
the last two elections so a political
grifter that doesn't fit Nikki Haley you
know Greg 59 of the black vote in South
Carolina is Republican Tim Scott may
enter the race and I wonder how that
breaks down vis-a-vis Nikki Haley and
Tim Scott is he black or white
I don't know I think you know you want
the picture yeah I think yeah I think I
need a picture I love that you can't
tell the difference does that mean that
Tim's not black enough or Rick's not
white enough you know what helped Whoopi
out a lot if one of them was Jewish then
she'd know who to blame yeah you know I
I I love the view I get at least one
segment every two weeks out of them uh
it's incredible and I think Geraldo is
right to some extent that it's all it's
all in the altar of ideology but at the
same time construction workers have
greater respect for women than women on
The View I I've never seen women more
vile to other women than on The View
they're hateful they they and and they
are blind to any woman's achievement
right Nikki Haley or the judge if if you
do not follow what they say so their
idea of diversity stops at diversity of
opinion if you don't agree with them
you're as good as scum to them so so
they're they're they are they're
misogynistic in in the in kind of in the
I don't know in the service of their
political beliefs and that makes it okay
to them Unlocking The Secret of the view
that's a new Fox Nation show hosted by
Geraldo yes hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else